un des 3 4 l'entraînement est intensif
pour les jeunes gymnastes en compétition
du club de gymnastique rythmique
d'elancourt maurepas 19 heures
d'entraînement par semaine auxquels
s'ajoutent des stages pendant les
vacances scolaires
chaque séance commence par une bonne
heure d'échauffement des 3 4 les filles
passent ensuite aux engins pour les
compétitions chaque gymnaste prépare un
enchaînement 2 minutes 30 avec un engin
imposé par la fédération c'est un
enchaînement qui entraîneurs préparent
que recherchent les musiques laethem en
tête chinois on coupe la musique c'est
énorme travail et après on travaille ça
pour préparer pour compétition les
filles se donnent à fond pour ce sport
mêlant la technique la souplesse et
l'artistique bananarama vais emmener
voir un gala de gym ici et puis
j'ai adoré du coup bas
en effet bas c'était le fait de pouvoir
essayer de me dépasser et faire mon
possible le plus pour évoluer et cd
d'être ban peut-être mieux placé fait
d'aimer pointe et direct doni claude
auxerre et à cers la professeur russe
fait du repérage dès le plus jeune âge
les petites semaines aux entraînements
des plus grandes qui leur montre la voie
plus on commence tôt et plus on se plie
aux règles et plus c'est facile
en fait pour travailler la souplesse
pour travailler la technique c'est des
bases qu'il faut acquérir très vite
parce que la grc une carrière à une
carrière qui s'arrêtent très tôt une
méthode qui porte ses fruits morgan a
fait partie de l'équipe de france sa
carrière de gymnaste de haut niveau
terminé elle aime revenir dans son club
de coeur
donner un coup de main à son ancien
coach